gaston defferre liberté et
responsabilité pour les élus locaux
le patron du 5 bientôt transféré à
marseille livre au sud liban un
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
météo c'est sûr il fera peut-être beau
beau soir depuis ce matin les députés
discutent du projet de loi sur la
décentralisation le débat se poursuivra
ce soir et toute la journée de demain
cette réforme des communes des
départements et des régions accroît le
pouvoir des collectivités locales dont
les décisions ne seront plus soumises un
accord préalable du préfet ou des
ministères concernés
en présentant ce projet de loi à gaston
defferre on a défini les grands
principes la liberté et la
responsabilité de jean mais les élus
seront libres libres d'exercer
pleinement leurs mandats livre de
prendre leurs responsabilités sans
entraves sont une limitation sur les
détournements imposé par les services
ministériels contre leur volonté
et parfois contre l'intérêt de leur
commune les députés ont repoussé la
question préalable posé par olivier
guichard et l'exception d'irrecevabilité
présenté par michel depret l'ancien
premier ministre estime que ce projet de
loi est incompatible avec plusieurs
dispositions de la constitution et qu'il
va à l'encontre de la conception
française de l'unité nationale où il
faut ouvertement modifier la
constitution où il faut ce qu'est ma
conclusion tout en affirmant une volonté
délibérée de décentralisation notamment
municipales et départementales maintenir
au président de la république au
parlement au gouvernement en charge de
l'état les moyens juridiques d'être ce
qu'ils sont l'expression active
quotidienne permanente de l'unité
nationale et de la légitimité de la
république mais monsieur devrait nous
sommes entièrement d'accord et je ne
proposerai
le texte soumis à l'assemblée qui puisse
laisser supposer que le gouvernement
veut faire passer la france d'une
constitution unitaire ou d'une
conception unitaire à une conception
fédérative vous savez comme moi ce que
c'est qu'une conception fédérative vous
savez que les états en allemagne par
exemple vote des lois dispose de la
police dispose de l'autorité judiciaire
de l'éducation nationale du contrôle de
l'inspection du travail toute chose
qu'ils essaient qui c'est spécifié en
termes parfaitement clair et ce n'est
pas seulement l'esprit c'est en toute
lettre des textes qui vous sont soumis
toutes choses qui ne sont pas accordés
aujourd'hui ni au vide ni le département
ni aux régions nous restons dans le cas
d'une conception et d'une constitution
unités et dire que c'est une conception
ou une constitution fédérative c'est une
erreur que vous avez commises à cette
tribune
cet échange en tout cas témoigne de
l'importance de ce débat sur la
décentralisation
un projet de loi qui a provoqué beaucoup
de discussions aujourd'hui un débat
suivi d'ailleurs par un très grand
nombre de députés jean louis le sen a
recueilli les commentaires de certains
autres peu d'animation dans les couloirs
de l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui les
députés présents étaient tous en séance
ou presque à noter cependant le
regroupement de tous les barons du
gaullisme sur les bancs de l'opposition
mais ce qu'il faut dire c'est que la
lassitude et les slogans appris par
coeur semblait être ce lundi le lot
commun des députés de l'ancienne
majorité à une discussion terne dans
l'hémicycle correspondait une absence
d'effervescence dans les couloirs
malgré les bons mots dont tout le monde
espère qu'ils deviendront très
rapidement des maux de têtes retournent
six ans en arrière au régime féodal où
on verra lé ladite la succession d'une
série d'administration
trois niveaux ce qui vont bigras
certainement beaucoup les choses pour
les citoyens tout comme le rpr et l'udf
dans son ensemble ressort
cependant certains s'abstient
c'est un texte important dans lequel il
y à des convergences de fond mais des
inquiétudes fondamentale donc nous ne
fermons pas la porte et nous attendons
les réponses à ce stade de la discussion
parlementaire du gouvernement et nous
attendons surtout les textes ultérieurs
qui font la vraie décision
à ceux qui s'étonnent de la
précipitation du gouvernement pour faire
voter son texte le parti socialiste
répond avec sérénité la force tranquille
en quelques sortes les parties gouverner
la france jusqu'à présent ont souvent
parlé de la décentralisation souvent
parlé de la régionalisation mais comme
celle est difficile à réaliser
eh bien ils n'ont rien entrepris nous
nous voulons d'entreprendre et nous
voulons entreprendre tout de suite
pour marc était le début de cette
nouvelle législature une volonté qui est
celle qui a été exprimée pendant la
campagne de françois mitterrand
mais la majorité n'est pas unanime si le
texte est bon on ne va pas assez loin
assez vite et il reste des points
d'interrogation
je souhaite qu'il y ait une plus grande
concertation des participations des élus
de l'organisation syndicale pour
l'élaboration des autres textes
je souhaite également que les moyens
financiers soient donnés pour réaliser
cette décentralisation et je souhaite
enfin que l'exil exécutive ne pèse pas
trop sur les petites communes et que le
contrôle a priori qui a été supprimée
que l'église il se passe par
l'autocensure en finale ce texte sera
voté sans difficulté les élus jugeront
en leur âme et conscience
tout en sachant pour ceux d'opposition
qu'il a encore à surmonter l'obstacle du
sénat
mais avec nous maintenant au direct de
l'assemblée nationale daniel brême alors
daniel au centre des discussions
aujourd'hui c'est poser le problème de
la constitutionnalité de ce projet qu'en
est-il de exactement quelle est votre
analyse hâtive j'écoute et je crois
qu'il faudra pour attendre le verdict du
conseil constitutionnel quand il sera
saisie sera un beau casse tête
en attendant je vais essayer de résumer
les arguments de monsieur de fer et de
monsieur debré qui ont tous d'eux
brandit la constitution pour en arriver
à des conclusions diamétralement
opposées alors monsieur debré affirme
que les préfets n'ont plus en charge la
défense des intérêts de la nation c'est
l'article 72 de la constitution et que
donc ils ne pourront plus faire
respecter les lois et il donne l'exemple
suivant si un conseil général du midi
décide de s'opposer à l'entrée dans le
département de fruits ou légumes d'un
pays de la communauté que pourra faire
le préfet il saisira le tribunal
administratif très bien mais pendant
combien de mois
durant combien nous attendre at-il le
verdict alors pendant ce temps là et
bien l'autorité de l'état sera pas fou
et mais pas du tout vous faites erreur
réplique vivement monsieur de faire les
pouvoirs des préfets seront augmentés et
comme ils seront responsables de la
police eh bien ils s'opposeront à cette
décision
du reste dans le petit larousse le mot
contrôle signifie vérification d'un acte
c'est donc la preuve que c'est bien
après et non avant que les préfets
doivent donner leur avis il faut
desserrer le carcan notre projet
respecte strictement la constitution ya
daniel les députés au fait référence
plusieurs fois
l'histoire au cours des débats oui ils
ont appelé à la rescousse napoléon iii
colbert le général de gaulle et même
parodier vers l'est et monsieur de fer
ayant traité monsieur debré de jacobins
ce dernier lui a fait appel au petit
robert pour déclarer que ce terme
signifier je cite celui qui est acquis
aux idées démocratiques à quoi monsieur
de faire a répliqué toujours aussi
vivement cette est vrai sous la
révolution en 1789
maintenant vous mériter le titre de
centralisateur nous nous sommes des
décentralisateur nous voulons vite
donner aux français le changement qu'ils
attendent la suite s'est tenue cette
réforme qui est considérée comme l'une
des plus importantes du gouvernement et
du septennat de françois mitterrand
provoquera des changements importants
dans la vie quotidienne des 36000
communes françaises lucie soboul
enquêter dans la région de grenoble dans
une petite commune agricole
le reportage de lucie foule maurice puis
ça à 58 ans il est maire de miribel en
châtre une de ces communes des
contreforts du vercors à une vingtaine
de kilomètres de grenoble
des mecs comme lui il y en a 22 mille en
france agriculteur c'est quotidiennement
qu'il s'est heurté à l'administration
ce qu'on ressentait d'une façon
permanente
c'était c'est cette contrainte qui était
apportée par justement l'autorité
préfectorale qui était pas seulement le
préfet de nous empêcher de réaliser ce
qu'on voulait réaliser même même alors
que quelquefois on avait les moyens de
le faire indirectement un certain nombre
de choses ne pouvaient pas se faire
parce que l'accord du préfet n'est pas
donné et la subvention afférents à cet
accord ne n'était pas accordé donc
l'écran devrait pas freiner
sur les 200 habitants de miribel en
châtre moins du quart est agriculteur
les autres travaillent à grenoble ceux
qui veulent vivre de la terre et c'est
d'améliorer grâce aux aides et
subventions la petite exploitation
familiale entre eux aussi dans un cycle
de démarches compliquées dotation jeune
agriculteur est d'abord instruit par un
organisme semi public est ensuite
transmis aux services départementaux qui
sont l'occurrence la direction
départementale de l'agriculture qui
ensuite passez par la délégation
régionale du duc n'a dit nadia et qui
ensuite mr d'agriculture finalement ça
fait ils ont pas mal de temps le budget
de la commune
cent soixante mille francs demain le
conseil municipal devait pouvoir par
exemple faire construire le
transformateur électrique la salle de
classe réclamé depuis plusieurs années
sans attendre une cascade d'autorisation
mais le village se développent des
grenoblois viennent installer leur
résidence principale ou secondaire
il faut que ça ait des routes d
adduction d'eau installé le tout à
l'égout pour tout cela le budget
communal suffira pas s'il est alimentée
que par les impôts locaux traditionnels
la réforme importante elle a surtout
porté sur la répartition différente de
l'impôt qui est levé dans le projet
socialiste qui devrait être mis en
application dans les semaines qui
suivent les ressources devraient
augmenter du fait d'une meilleure
répartition des crédits qui sont
actuellement un casse et d'un liquide
par les caisses de l'état et puis que
l'autre parent que ce soit et commune
elle même qui puisse disposer de cette
dotation est décidée elle même si l'on
s'ils vont faire adduction d'eau si
elles vont faire les qualifications ou
s'ils vont faire les routes
de nombreux maires de petites communes
apprécier les techniques de
l'administration
aujourd'hui il leur faut apprendre à
gérer seul le budget municipal
c'est presque un nouveau métier je crois
effectivement que ça va ça va poser
ensemble de problèmes aux élus qui vont
devoir assumer les responsabilités que
quelquefois ils évitaient de d'assumer
et il se retranchait justement des
recettes plus talent pour ne pas prendre
de responsabilité mais qui d'autre part
aussi il sera soumis sera nécessaire que
les élus chaptes de réaliser ce qu'ils
ont une réalisée même si sa mécontents
grimpent d'un recteur toujours à
l'assemblée nationale mais cette fois ci
dans les couloirs les députés ont évoqué
la tuerie d'auriol et le rôle joué par
le sac
les députés udf rpr l'est entendre que
ce crime est exploitée politiquement
alors que les élus de la majorité
évoquent très clairement les méfaits de
cette organisation
c'est une association qui au départ et
en particulier leurs sa création en 1958
avait des intentions fort louable
mais qui petit à petit au fil des années
notamment après la disparition du
général de gaulle 7 je dirais gangrène
et qu'est ce que vous allez dire quand
vous dites fort louable fort louable
c'est à dire comme toute association
elle avait des buts politiques
fait normal normaux cela dit je répète
aujourd'hui nous savons que cette
association a pu couvrir des opérations
de banditisme des violences électorales
très nombreuses
le mot sac a été mélangée à des trafics
de drogue à des meurtres à des rackets
qui sont totalement insupportable c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs j'ai demandé au nom
de mon groupe
l'interdiction de cette organisation
clandestine subversive et une commission
denquête pour faire la clarté nous
sommes nous pour la liberté
d'association la plus totale mais pas
pour des organisations de ce type qui
mélange le banditisme le milieu et les
autorités politiques du côté de la
majorité rien à dire sur le sac
aujourd'hui dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée du moins rien de public
rien d'officiel le sac n'est plus rien
disette en confidence un député du df
depuis le départ de georges pompidou
depuis ce ne sont que de petites bandes
rivales on veut nous faire un procès
d'intention un procès politique
répondait à son tour un élu du rpr la
chasse aux sorcières politique est
devenue telle et prend une telle ampleur
que pour répondre à la question bleus
sacs qu'est ce que c'est il faut
vraiment de nos jours être inculpé par
un juge d'instruction et vouloir se
faire de la publicité dans l'immédiat le
sac
connais pas pierre debizet le secrétaire
général du sac détenu à la prison de
fleury mérogis sera transféré ce soir ou
demain matin à marseille pour
comparaître devant le juge d'instruction
chargé du dossier de la tuerie d'auriol
il y sera confronté avec les quatre
autres inculpés le point sur l'enquêté
aujourd'hui avec notre envoyé spécial
isabelle bechler à marseille la juge
françoise boivin poursuit ses auditions
aujourd'hui c'est la partie civile qui
ont été entendus en la personne de
marine hamas y est la soeur de
l'inspecteur assassiné le juge s'est
ensuite rendu avec elle sur le lieu du
crime à la bastide de riols un moment
particulièrement pénible pour la soeur
de la victime
mais c'est de placement judiciaire était
inévitable car le juge n'avait pas
encore visité la bastide émacié voilà
pour les faits la suite de l'enquêté et
pour demain matin à moins d'un coup de
théâtre dans la nuit
il est vrai que si on a retrouvé la nuit
dernière la r5 dans laquelle jacques
massié s'étaient déplacés juste avant sa
mort on n'a toujours pas de trace des
cinq corps du reste de la famille
demain le juge françoise guérin doit
entendre bruno finaux piety
l'instituteur celui qui a avoué son
crime et on pense à marseille que cette
audition est un préalable pour celle de
monsieur pierre debizet le secrétaire
général du sac qui est toujours
incarcéré à paris car son nom figurerait
dans la déposition du meurtrier ces
fines ok tu y ait laissé entendre à la
police que pierre debizet avait
commandité le crime de jacques massié ce
n'est bien sûr pas l'opinion de l'avocat
du et adjoint au maire aixois yves
destrem ancien chef régional du sac
oui je connais effectivement très bien
je connais c'est effectivement très bien
à l'inspecteur massy je connais très
bien maria je connais surtout
parfaitement bien piano miser avec qui
j'ai des rapports d'amitié depuis dix
ans depuis que je le connais et je tiens
à préciser que je m'insurge contre tout
ce qui peut être dit contre lui dans le
cadre de cette affaire et ne connaissant
comme l'homme qu'il est c'est à dire un
homme infiniment bon qui ne peut en
aucun cas être m'aider à une affaire de
ce genre
avez vous assisté à ce fameux repas
longtemps par le temps au maintenant
aucun cas lorsque pierre debizet à
l'occasion de se déplacer dans la région
tant pour les vacances ou pour des
affaires personnelles il est bien
entendu qu'il m'a averti et qu'à chaque
fois j'ai et je fais le bon possible
pour l'heure encore et j'ai rencontré
pierre devise et c'est vrai au sofitel
marignale pendant une vingtaine de
minutes puis l'équité à ce moment là et
je n'ai participé à aucun repas dans
cette affaire d'auriol dont on parle
tant vous m'avez dit tout à l'heure hors
entretien que pour vous c'était un crime
crapuleux
qu'entendez-vous par là j'entends par là
qu'il m'apparaît impossible que ce soit
une affaire politique
connaissant le service d'action civique
depuis longtemps et sachant qu'il
n'aimait n'est en rien à ce genre de
d'affaires et que par ailleurs lorsque
j'entends parler de fonds cela me fait
malheureusement je ne peux pas dire
sourire dans le contexte d'affaires mais
me mets en deux mois étant donné qu'il
s'agissait il s'agit toujours d'une
organisation qui paie qui fait payer à
ses adhérents une cotisation de 50
francs par an et que la location que
j'avais voix à l'époque en tant que
départemental étaient 200 francs oui m
destrem avaient été relâchés dimanche
soir après 24 heures de garde à vue
l'extrémiste de droite espagnol ernesto
milla rodriguez a été condamné à six
mois de prison pour recel de faux
papiers
il avait été entendu dans le cadre de l'
enquête sur l'attentât de la rue
copernic
à l'étranger yasser arafat le chef de la
résistance palestinienne estime que l'ol
paie est devenue une réalité pour les
américains et donc que la politique des
etats-unis vis-à-vis des palestiniens a
changé dans une interview accordée à une
chaîne de télévision américaine
yasser arafat a déclaré que les forces
palestiniennes avaient réussi à tenir
tête à l'impressionnante machine de
guerre israélo américaines sur le
terrain de cessez le feu semble fragile
les palestiniens accusent israël d'avoir
tiré sur l'une de leurs positions et
toute la matinée l'aviation israélienne
a survolé la région et ça pour la
première fois depuis le début de la
trêve au sud liban où les bombardements
ont fait plus de 500 morts en une
semaine une partie importante de la
population rend les palestiniens
responsables des bombardements
israéliens
une enquête de philippe rochot et de
jean-louis saporito
le pétrole brûlis si depuis quatre jours
depuis que l'aviation israélienne a
bombardé cet oléoduc qui apportait au
liban cet or noir qu'il ne possède pas
en frappant ici israël a voulu paralysé
le ravitaillement des véhicules
militaires palestiniens il faudra
plusieurs semaines pour le réparer les
fedayin été visé ce sont pourtant les
libanais qui ont payé essence rationner
pour ne mois dans tout le pays alors que
les combattants palestiniens en priorité
pour se servir fort ici les sens ce
n'est pas un luxe car le liban sud a
soif soif de ce carburant qui fait
rouler ce camion démarche en effet
tourné aussi l'économie agricole ça fait
combien de temps que vous attendez ici
pour avoir de l'essence si nabatiyé la
plus grande ville du sud liban a été
bombardé c'est surtout parce que les
fedayin ont établi leur quartier général
ils quadrillent la ville font la police
la loi et la justice c'est un état fort
dans un état faible
pour finir ici il faut cacher la caméra
ils ne veulent pas montrer qu'ils sont
les vrais maîtres de la cité l'autorité
libanaise l'autorité légale est dépassée
comme le maire de nabatiyé jamais vu
l'avenir il n'y a pas de palestiniens
ils sont à la frontière un peu plus loin
on n'en voit pas ici d'un côté les
libanais de l'autre les palestiniens
mais il n'y a pas de problème entre eux
ces présents se trouvaient à côté d'une
permanence palestinienne grisé par la
bourde des israéliens son propriétaire a
tout perdu sauf la vie il était aux
abris quand l'obus a frappé les
palestiniens étaient visés
c'est lui qui a payé pourtant il reste
encore trois mille habitants dans cette
ville qui en comptait autrefois plus de
50000 pourquoi vous restez ici mais il
ya des gens qui pas d'argent l'argent
parce que vous pouvez pas aller ailleurs
elle même et si vous travaillez ici et
si vous en mettez pas un peu la
responsabilité sur les palestiniens
aussi ben non non non c'était pas là
vous n'aurez pas choquer les
palestiniens sont
et les leur patrie si l'ensemble sans
lâcher un arbre ils ont le droit de
défendre
ddd vous savez défendre leur patrie
c'est là bas qu'ils sont nuls ils ont
été chassés comme le chien à cause des
bombardements nabatiyé n'a pas reçu de
farine pendant 10 jours mais on se garde
bien ici d'en faire porter la
responsabilité aux fedayin palestiniens
le richmond tion des bâtiments klein que
ça ils sont pas de correct palestiniens
parce que ils disent que le bombardement
israélien
c'est à cause d'eux les palestiniens ne
peut pas dire ça il ya des gens qui
comprend vraiment pourquoi les
palestiniens
cette bière dit ah les palestiniens donc
qu'il ya les bombardements mais s'il n'y
avait pas les patients du bas qui a pas
de prendre part dont les bombardements
israéliens sur les routes les villages
et les ponts ont fait plus de 500 morts
en une semaine
parmi la population du sud liban les
libanais profitent du cessez le feu pour
compter leurs morts
comme cette famille qui vient de
retrouver la voiture où se trouvaient
l'un des siens déchiqueté par une bombe
de 500 kg
vous aviez de la famille là vous aviez
de la famille monsieur
oui sans flash c'était son frère pour et
du design ils traversaient pour pour ses
affaires pour le commerce
à belfast l'état de santé de kieran
doherty s'est gravement détériorée ce
prisonniers de la prison de max et la
grève de la faim depuis 67 jours six
prisonniers républicains sont déjà morts
depuis le début du mouvement de grève de
la faim qui a commencé le 1er mars
dernier
gérard ce bac mais la trop célèbre
prison de longue qu'aient en irlande du
nord
la prison bloc h en raison de la
construction de ces bâtiments en forme
de h c'est ici que sont emprisonnés les
terroristes de l'ira l'organisation des
catholiques d'irlande du nord
c'est également ici que sont morts déjà
six membres de l'ira qui faisait la
grève de la faim six morts dont le
premier fut bobby sands députés au
parlement britannique le 5 mai dernier
depuis le mouvement des prisonniers qui
font la grève de la faim se poursuit
tant l'un meurt un autre membre de l'ira
prend la relève
un mouvement qui ne semble pas vouloir
s'arrêter face à l'intransigeance de
londres émane thatcher que demandent les
membres de l'ira même plus le statut
politique simplement le droit de porter
des vêtements civils et celui de ne pas
être mêlés aux prisonniers de droit
commun
avant d'entamer cette campagne de grève
de la faim les prisonniers de l'ira
refusé de se vêtir et barbouiller les
murs de leur cellule d'excréments
en pologne protestation toujours contre
la pénurie alimentaire des autobus de
lot ont défilé aujourd'hui pour
protester contre le mauvais
approvisionnement de la population la
france critique la tchécoslovaquie à
l'occasion de l'ouverture à prague du
procès de l'un des porte parole de la
charte 77 rudolph patek un communiqué du
quai d'orsay constate le non respect par
la tchécoslovaquie de l'acte final
d'helsinki
et puis diplomatie toujours avec
l'entretien accordé par claude cheysson
en agence centrale de presse le ministre
des relations extérieures y rappelle que
les relations franco soviétique ne sont
pas normales en raison de la présence
soviétique en afghanistan et que cette
situation exclu sa visite en urs alors
qu'il y avait été invité georges bortoli
on mais je crois que le propos est très
clair et il marque un durcissement de la
position française sur l'afghanistan par
rapport si vous voulez à la position du
précédent gouvernement français
j'ai enfin tout petit peu d'histoire pas
très lointaine on se souvient que les
rencontres des ministres des affaires
étrangères français juillet tickets non
seulement habituel mais qu'elle était
institutionnelle en quelque sorte
s'était inscrit sur les tablettes pas
monsieur gromyko qui est le ministre des
affaires étrangères cheville éthique
depuis près d'un quart de siècle
maintenant avait l'habitude de
rencontrer son collègue français deux
fois par an bon ça c'était un peu
ralenti depuis la sphère l'afghanistan
c'est même beaucoup ralenti puisque le
dernier voyage de monsieur gromyko à
paris date est tout de même d'abris 80
maintenant de ce ralentissement on passe
à une espèce de suspension jusqu'à un
nouvelle radio chez sont dit non je
n'irai pas à moscou wafi suis invitée ce
n'est pas surprenant si vous voulez si
dans le droit fil des propos que
françois mitterrand tenait à ronald
reagan
la semaine dernière à ottawa et puis ça
veut pas dire bien sûr qu'il n'y aura
plus de contacts font crochet viêt est
évident que monsieur besson est magique
revenir au courant on parlait par
exemple en septembre prochain à new york
au moment de l'assemblée générale des
nations unies mais tout de même il faut
bien dire que le temps des rapports
privilégiés franco soviétique est
terminée si vous laisser le temps de la
détente et vous savez de la détente
après laffaire d'afghanistan après
l'installation des chemins soviétique en
europe et puis bauchi depuis le nouveau
cours
de la politique américaine il faut bien
dire que la détente on en parle surtout
au passé économie maintenant avec une
hausse de 1% de l'indicé des prix en
juin ce qui représente une hausse de 6,5
pour cent des prix depuis le début de
l'année le ministère de l'économie
souligne ce soir que l'inflation reste
en france un phénomène préoccupant et
l'insee de son côté est pessimiste en
prévoyant une accélération de la hausse
au second semestre qui porterait
l'inflation à 14,5 pour cent pour
l'ensemble de l'année
andré bergeron lance l'idée d'un emprunt
pour financer l'indemnisation du chômage
le secrétaire général de force ouvrière
estime qu'un emprunt sur 15 ans
permettrait de faire face aux
difficultés actuelles sans conséquences
pour les salariés ou pour le budget de
l'état
l'administration des douanes a donné
l'ordre aux postes-frontières alsacien
de contrôler plus étroitement les
passages éventuelle d'une quarantaine de
responsables d'entreprises de groupe à
gages ville aux halles il est le
président de l'antenne régionale du cnpf
monsieur anar estime que les frères
villo sont livrés à la vindicte publique
réaction inverse au comité d'entreprise
de boussenac son frère ce qui nous
semble intéressant voile affaire c'est
que qui a les biens immobiliers des
vélos soit
hypothéquer de façon à dégager une
garantie
du côté du gouvernement que l'argent
puisse être récupéré et à ce niveau là
on souhaiterait que l'argent qui
appartient actuellement tout
l'immobilier et tous de l'argent qui
appartient aux huiles aux soient
réintégrés dans la société parce que à
la partie affectée par un accident de
car au maroc a provoqué la mort de cinq
personnes dont quatre français qui
passaient leurs vacances au club
méditerranée
douze autres touristes français ont été
blessés et rapatriés par avion sanitaire
les départs en vacances de samedi
provoque déjà les mises en garde de
bison futé six millions de français
seront sur les routes des bouchons
ininterrompue sont prévus au départ de
paris et de lyon
bison futé vous conseille donc de
prendre la route que dimanche ou même
lundi si vous avez le courage d'attendre
en sport la tournée des springboks sans
nouvelle zélande continuera et cela
malgré les incidents qui ponctuent
presque tous les déplacements de
l'équipe sud-africaine de rugby en
tennis le français thierry tulasne
remporté la finale du simple messieurs
de l'open de suède
je rappelle que tulasne avait refusé de
participer avec l'équipe de france à la
coupe de galéa et puis un autre français
le jeune skieur nautique patrice martin
une fois de plus fait admirer son très
beau style en remportant l'épreuve de
figure des jeux mondiaux des sports non
olympiques de californie après
carpentras et avignon nous vous
présentons ce soir le festival de vaison
la romaine ou jusqu'au 13 août vous
pourrez voir des pièces de théâtre
écouter du jazz entendre léo ferré qui
fréquentent les festivals et pourquoi
une enquête de you back ricouart
dans toutes les villes où un festival
officiel attire du public le spectacle
est aussi dans la rue vaison la romaine
n'échappe pas à ce phénomène culturel
spontanée l'environnement historique de
vaison vieille de 2000 ans avec un
dépliant touristique chargée ruines
romaines bourg médiéval château du comte
de toulouse pourrait suffire à combler
le touriste est pourtant pas
complètement puisque si on peut
comprendre qu'une population de 8000
habitants en hiver passe à 20000 en
pleine saison
on peut se poser des questions quant au
chiffre de 50 mille personnes qui
fréquentent le festival
l'engouement d'une région et donc aussi
culturel pour 60 % de gens et les
municipalités le savent puisque l'on
compte à l'heure actuelle quelques 500
villes festivalières en france
j'y vais de temps en temps avec un des
parents c'est une ambiance très
sympathique
le club de spectacle
prenez la musique les cycles de quatre
heures ah non absolument pas tu aimes tu
as tu fais de la musique et même oui
alors je fais de l'alto tout le monde
non pas du tout le monde attendait ce
festival
mais je vous assure qu'on est très
content au sort sa carte d'invitation
oui je voudrais vous dire ce que tu en
penses trop rien
dans un cadre très agréable puisque ces
intrants ticket merveilleux
nous trouvons à la fois le
l'agrément de l'endroit et la variété
dans l'esprit
l'acoustique pour vous comment une si
petite ans parce qu'une des meilleures
je suis probablement la meilleure des
autres quand nous sommes venus à l'écran
il ya deux ans il y avait les traits
très gros problème et ils ont trouvé un
espèce du 6ème mois ils ont mis à un mur
et c'est une espèce de choses magiques
comme ça brusquement le soin de nous
très beau et franchement c'est très beau
il vous avez choisi votre programme en
fonctionne pas si vous même qui l'avait
choisie en avons parlé bien sûr ça me
trouvais beaucoup plaisir de faire les
neuf ça fait une méthode c'est toujours
très intéressant à faire surtout en cinq
concerts ça nous l'avons fait et puis à
des choses que leur cage joue très
souvent et je peux dire très bien qu'ils
parlent de leur quête du vrai que le
verdict a remis mais ces choses là et en
plus de ça j'ai de très très bons amis
chanteurs à qui j'ai demandé de venir et
qui très gentiment sont venus en force
et tu es vraiment une espèce de fête
pour nous c'était sympathique on s'est
retrouvé tout son sens très bien
la fête était aussi pour le public ce
soir là puisque de 4500 places assises
que contient le théâtre il y avait six
mille personnes venues entendre l'hymne
à la joie
pour
oh
nous verrons
le temps demain très vite alain
gillot-pétré ce que vous prévoyez un
petit peu plus de soleil oui mais
n'aborde et brumeux le matin puis du
soleil l'après midi les températures ont
fait un bond aujourd'hui vous l'avez vu
elles étaient presque toutes au dessus
de 20 degrés encore ne s'agit-il là que
les températures de 14 heures dans
l'après midi encore monter la prévision
pour demain sur notre carte
isobar et qui va se découvrir devant
vous très simple j'ai fait abstraction
de toutes les dépressions demain un
anticyclone une ramification dans
l'anticyclone des açores qui fait qu' il
n'y aura donc de l'air stable avec des
brumes le matin du soleil l'après-midi
des brumes car le parcours de l'air est
quand même essentiellement maritime
quand ils arrivent sur notre pays alors
là prévisions pour demain très
brièvement je voulais déjà dit donc des
brumes et des nuages le matin qui se
dissiperont dans la journée sur presque
tout le pays de belles éclaircies
en revanche des ardennes à l'alsace un
petit peu de bruine le matin ça devrait
s'arranger
dans l'après-midi la prévision de
température pour demain presque normale
sachez que depuis le début du mois du
juillet sur 27 jours il ya eu trois
jours de températures normales et 24
jours de températures en dessous des
normes saisonnières et où il a fait
froid enfin notre effet mairie pour
demain les heurts du soleil 6h29 33 et
la fête des sens au mardi 28 juillet le
dernier journal vous sera présentée par
chaque merlino vers 23h15
et puis demain antenne 2010 sera
réalisée en direct de londres
bonsoir merci de votre attention